là
irène chagnoux propose voyage sans
passeport
belem do para latitude zéro
c'est là que se trouve l'embouchure de
l'amazone pression accrue pour montrer
son modernisme belem do para des autobus
oui mais en forme d'avion
mais ces arbres gigantesques sont
fidèles eux passés amazonien
à
vert aux pêcheurs
voir le poids et le non support il
revient du cris des marchands qui a su
un peu bien sûr leur balance plus juste
que celle du voisin jardin à la
française les ils sont taillés en forme
d'animaux voici le marchand de haut elle
se vend là bas au litre comme le lait qu
ici tout est contraste la misère côtoie
la richesse et pendant que les airs ou
une voiture de luxe
les autres les cas blockhaus métis
portugais et noir se déplacent à dos de
mulet surtout dans les plantations de
cocotiers
ces femmes vous croiriez transporter
tout d'un coup par exemple à la ville du
puy eh bien pas du tout vous êtes
toujours à belem do para latitude zéro
soda du merveille soda dit gedo
c'est caboclo ce en majorité pêcheurs
bangladais yves roche ont deux amours la
mer enora ganda raddho qui leur permet
d'aller dessus elle est faite de 5,30
balsa en bois très léger et là dessus il
reste trois et quatre jours en mer en
haute mer
non
même montant
chemin
non
eauze autant ils vivent là les pieds
dans l'eau parfois la 3d vocale
quelquefois la merde valait tout leur
pêche il rentre soigne mais quand tout
va bien la vie est heureuse à bord en
effet la cuisine
dans une écuelle de bois sur un tambour
de filets de pêche
chico nombreux tours 1 soon as des
statines a peur gilbert aubry touraine
sur ses statuts n'a pas dansé paille
amoureux
je sais que je suis content non ces
failles à bourg sur ce coup ci contre à
gauche
la soupe est mélangé de haricots noirs
et de vous le haricot noir les aliments
principaux on y ajoute quelques morceaux
de poisson ou de viande séchée
le nettoyage est vite fait la soupe
mélange de farine de manioc les pêcheurs
en font des boulettes
ils refusent ces hommes des bateaux de
pêche normaux lara ganda et leurs biens
presque leur vue
bintou keita thomas de genou de figures
peintes ou quand un bon match mais ils
se partageront entre eux leurs maigres
une super tottenham un gars c't'un gars
agenda sa e-boutique ou ses débuts
vous tous
aussant
en somme beaucoup de peine pour peu de
résultats
le voici dans l'intérieur du nord-est
là se trouve le camp d'assaut le sertao
la peine sèche du désert il n'y a pas
d'eau là bas quelquefois il ne veut pas
pendant un an deux ans alors ils ne
poussent que détecter les caboclo ce
fils et petit-fils dé cangaceiros les
bandits du nord-est gardent leur petit
bétail n'y vivent de peut toujours en
selle avec leurs chapeaux et leur veste
de pluie
là
je suis n'a pas sauvé
m
à
la vidéo
à fait
on aime ou la vie des français
y prennent soin de les couper ce cactus
ils habitent dans ces phases honda
bahia perle du nord
elle vit autour de son vieux port
on est superstitieux à bahia et les
femmes se protègent du mauvais oeil
avec ce efficace vous voyez en groupe à
rudy kg et ses ornements seront
scrupuleusement répétés sur les poupées
de leurs enfants
orné dabou bracelet de colifichets de
porte bonheur
et maintenant vous avez assisté à la
macumba pour être tout à fait honnête je
vous dois de préciser que c'est une
reconstitution macumba la macumba et
dans le vaudou du brésil
elle lui la religion chrétienne avec les
dieux africain
c'est d'une novice qui se prosternent au
pied de la mer du sac
teliris la cérémonie et transmet et
libère l'esprit saint la musique bat une
mesure qui va de plus en plus vite
et puis commence la ronde et les
incantations qui permettront à l'esprit
du sein de venir sur terre et de
s'incarner dans un des membres de la
macumba
ces manips et 6 qui lui a vu la macumba
le battement des tambours tournoiement
de la ronde bruit des clochettes les
paroles rituelles et surtout la volonté
d'être possédé qui permet à la rumba de
rester plus vivante que jamais quand il
ne s'agit pas d'une reconstitution les
femmes sont vêtus uniquement de robes
blanches
irène chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours est un film de
george p 6 et de cela fait taire son
anniv béni montage claude richard
illustration sonore de lys gazelle
à
au bras